[Music]
Johnny yes sir gadget
yes sir
major
yep
okay
yes sir
yes
yeah
yeah
did you guys check focus
Ferdie that getting a little old
what's the verdict Doug stand by
are you
today they afternoon tea and we're about
24 minutes late for the briefing but we
do expect it will happen soon leads you
to get the president's got an event
which is supposed to serve about five
minutes so somehow they have to work at
the schedule to your point the president
Trump pushing back against criticism of
that upcoming morality in Tulsa Oklahoma
the president pointing at the same
people who are being critical of him
were not critical of the large crowds
began from the streets across America
over the last couple of weeks some of
which resulted in violent demonstrations
the president quitting the far-left fake
news media which had no covered problem
with the rioters and looters destroying
democrat run cities is trying to cope in
chambers on our big rallies won't work
and we should point out that the
director of the Tulsa in Tulsa County
Health Department has encouraged the
president to push back the rally from
Saturday night saying there's been a
spike of coronavirus cases in Oklahoma
putting a large crowd into the BOK arena
probably isn't a good idea at this time
there were 225 news coronavirus cases in
the state of Oklahoma on Saturday that
number of them down to 158 as of
yesterday the Republican mayor in the
city of Tulsa GT diamond he is
encouraging the president supportive of
that political rally coming up on
Saturday by tweeting but it's also we
protect a free and peaceful exchange of
ideas we did during the last two weeks
of protests and we will do it during the
president visit itself the next week we
will also continue to follow the state
of Oklahoma's guidelines for say free
openers as you have pointed out the
president did push that rally back by
the day the original date this Friday
the 19th is Juneteenth which is
celebrated by African Americans across
the country is a traditional day of
emancipation
that's when the Union General landed on
Galveston Island and set free everyone
who was enslaved there the Trump
campaign reported that more than 800
people have registered for this event
the arena holds only 19,000 so some
seven hundred eighty thousand people
won't be able to attend but I think it's
safe to say Dana that most of those
people probably just registered because
they wanted to show their support would
probably know attention that you're
going to do that
thank you
sorry
yes okay we tell you Brian
wasted petition there were no other
seats on the other side
so they know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
thank you so much thank you
we're one week into New York City's
reopening and I'm here to check out how
Chinatown has been doing the
neighborhood has been hit particularly
hard by the coronavirus economically
because of his dependence on tourism
restaurant and retail all of which have
been suffering during the coronavirus
starting as early as January because of
people's prejudice against the Chinese
today I'm going to talk to some of the
small businesses and see how they are
doing as they navigate the reopening I'm
now outside of Nahuatl e-power
my iconic in some place in Chinatown
usually you'd see people lining up
outside waiting as much as one hour just
to be seated now the restaurant is only
offering takeout and delivery you can
see that a few people are sitting
outside waiting for their dim sum it
would slow my first one the lock down
first started but then there was a lot
of panic buying but now slowly
everyone's opening back twelve but
there's not enough foot traffic for all
of us to
my business would really realize on a
weekend customers are the ones that are
from out of state or a little out of
town
hopefully it gets better as this is only
phase one that's coming out Jamaicans
are Yahoo topic I was really speaking
with mrs. hansal ever answer the double
yahoo party that we think I had to buy a
life to a suit or a pound I try to make
my year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
despite the challenges that we may have
in some of the countries we tried to
keep the door open for continuous clever
people drink in Tanzania is that we
never stop the interaction with the
ministries maybe we were not receiving a
regular data but at least we were
continual to advise them on what needs
to be done it is another step for them
to take it into account and implemented
only last week of the ministry reply if
it emerges in the field out of the
capital city and dr. Joe was asked to
join the team
so is at least improved even if we don't
have data being shared with the world
but at least they are opening up to
accept our support our advice
Tamia Martin Campbell is a move to the
other animal not a tamales Anna moon now
a taqueria DC movie Azharuddin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm joined by designer and founder
Aurora James from brother bellies who
came up with a way for companies to
actually show their solidarity aside
from just posting on social media the 15
percent pledge is a business-to-business
ask so we're asking Target Whole Foods
we're asking shop and Nordstrom to come
to the table and commit 15% of their
purchased power to black owns businesses
that means their shelf space anyone that
they're working with their vendors
really trying to hit 50 percent and have
some awareness around what they're doing
and how they're spending their money
we're incredibly excited to announce
before us taking the pledge the ones
that we haven't heard from they're
silences of course deafening the black
community and also hope America is
waiting it's not like this is a request
from just black people this is a request
from everyone this started out as a
simple ask that I may need on my own
private channel and we now have almost a
hundred thousand names on a petition
these are very real customers that are
calling on all of these businesses to
step up and take the 15% pledge we saw a
lot of brands posting the black square a
lot of people posting the black square
and black out Tuesday and some people
prefer to that as being a little bit
performative I think for a lot of brands
is easier for those who just likes black
square then talk about what they wanted
to do I was seeing but I wasn't
necessarily feeling it I really wanted
to start understanding what kind of
actionable change it would take them in
order for me as a black woman and a
business owner to feel supported it's
easy to write a check a lot of them
rights all the time but it's a lot
harder to commit to long-term growth and
also accountability and we can all help
you make the American business land
better and more fair you're really
pooling those resources intellectually
to figure out how to get over some of
these Turtles that's all we're asking
for
I'm not asking people for a black box
black box isn't gonna save lives or
uplift communities that really need it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
although come to the middle and our car
since I tied him with our cow the icon
near the kungfu panda oh dear God
ee No
then son Leonardo hi save yourself
you're going to kick ass Inka at that
time you may know some Jericho with
thunder gothic say to tiger jump okay no
offense official title town to my panda
able to conceive an e-commerce began can
kill you Hawk colder than a hotel she
kind of God don't worry about a goal
from the move our modular I don't
[Music]
a circle D oh my called the new coil of
the committee like John of Gaunt you how
that standing there
you develop a variety of aquatic Citra
lint anti-german multi-compo McCullum
cigarettes computing interconnect but I
sigh supercenters and audience who could
be indeed a phantom so incoming in toto
do ya
yes thank you I will tell me how the
other girls told I think you how to
adore so the whole region tonight until
the something bad intentions indeed
tooth or DKA
I thought I got a tango bombing there
are community together of toga
I reckon couch originality doyoung with
them take our world for half we'll take
a Sangha pick a one ting ting kau
internal dialogue yoga
so educating finding God now some TV
Ben Covington shall donkey totally
digging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
there's never been this much effort
there's never been this much money spent
we're taking good care of them and thank
you all very much thank you on your
executive order tomorrow can you tell us
sort of the broad brushstrokes of police
use of force reform as well as enhancing
opportunities communities across the
country and the segment for tomorrow
John but basically we're going to be
talking about things that we've been
watching and seeing for the last month
and we're gonna have some solutions I
think some good solutions and some of it
as you know it's about great people we
need great people in our police
departments and we have mostly great
people I would say that I would say that
was certainty we have mostly great
people I knows so many of them law
enforcement but we we will do better
even better and we're going to try and
do it fast so we're gonna have a meeting
tomorrow we're gonna have a news
conference tomorrow we have a lot of law
enforcement coming in and others and
they have seen what we're doing I've
sent it around I've asked for
suggestions from different groups in
particularly the sheriff's and I've sent
it to our Attorney General and I think
bill you've gone to some of your people
with it and shown it I think it's pretty
comprehensive as you know Congress is
also working on it the Senate's working
on something and the house is working on
two elements of the house you have the
Republicans and the Democrats and
they're each working on their own but we
can get it done and we'll get it done
and certainly we can add on to what we
do by the work that's being done in the
house and in the Senate if we think it's
appropriate maybe they can get something
passed and maybe they can't but we will
get it passed and it's got to be passed
by one person and the person's me so
we're going to be signing it tomorrow
and we'll have a news conference at some
point in the day at the Rose Garden or
maybe in front of the White House at a
different location that you know very
well the steps and we'll see you
tomorrow
come on guys what's the overall goal of
the executive order in all of these
reforms oh and the overall goal is we
want law and order and we want it done
fairly justly we want it done safely but
we want a lot order this is about a loan
order but it's about it's about justice
also and it's about safety so I think
we're going to do a good job tomorrow I
think you're going to see some things
that a lot of people thought would not
happen you wouldn't be able to get them
done but we'll get them done again
though I want to emphasize it's possible
the house can also on top of this I
spoke to the various leaders on top of
this can get something but I think this
will be very comprehensive tomorrow so
you'll see something I thought it was a
terrible I'm not going to compare things
but I thought it was a terrible
situation I studied it closely I'm gonna
get some reports done today of her
strong reports and we'll have a little
more to say about it tomorrow but
certainly it was very to me it was very
disturbing ruled I've read the decision
and some people were surprised but
they've ruled and we live with that
decision that's what it's all about we
live with the decision of the Supreme
Court very powerful a very powerful
decision actually but if they have so
ruled please go ahead
recommendation for malaria I'd like to
ask Alex maybe to discuss that sure so
just to clarify your statement there I
don't think was quite accurate and what
the FDA's action was the the FDA at the
request of Barda which is an agency
within HHS withdrew an emergency use
authorization for product that we had
acquired into the national stockpile by
donation from Mayor of hydroxyl of
chloroquine that was manufactured in
Pakistan and the EU a the emergency use
authorization was restricted for
Hospital use inpatient hospital use of
the product with the FDA finding that
they don't see enough data to support
hospital based use for those who are the
most extreme cases of patients has been
hospitalized they they took that
restriction off they took the emergency
use authorization off at this point
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine are
just like any other approved drug in the
United States they may be used in
hospital they may be used in outpatient
they may be used at home all subject to
a doctor's prescription
in fact the FDA's removal of the
emergency use authorization takes away
what had been a significant
misunderstanding by many that had made
people think that somehow it could only
be used in a hospital setting and we've
tried to make that clear throughout it's
a drug it's approved in the United
States has been for decades if a doctor
wishes to prescribe it working with the
patient they may prescribe it for any
purpose that they wish to do so
and this actually removes a potential
barrier to that so it actually
uncomplicated
in a way I think that's probably your
question was very in accurately stated
question
accurately I believe what it
specifically with it's no longer
reasonable in the hospital it said the
data in the hospital setting was not
supportive we continue the study in
outpatient settings as well as
preventive that data is not yet in no
that's why the FDA acted was that they
looked at the data and they removed the
emergency use authorization for hospital
setting use of the chloroquine that was
the bayer product that had been donated
from pakistan today you tweeted that you
believed that you were being coded
chained because they were decision to go
ahead with Tulsa rally on Saturday night
the director of the health department in
the county and in the city has
encouraged you to postpone that say they
still think that they've got too big a
Kobe problem for you to pull off a rally
like that your thoughts on well
Oklahoma's done very well I just spoke
to the governor he's very excited about
it
governor stead who's done a terrific job
Mike I think you can maybe speak to this
he's done a great job
Oklahoma's at a very low number they've
done a really fantastic work they have a
new a pretty new magnificent arena as
you probably have heard and we're
getting exact numbers out but we're
either close to or over 1 million people
wanting to go we have a 22 thousand seat
arena but I think we're going to also
take the convention hall next door and
that's going to hold 40,000 so of 22,000
plus 40,000 which would mean that would
have over 900,000 people that won't be
able to go but hopefully they'll be
watching but it's a it's an amazing
nobody's ever heard of numbers like this
I think we're gonna have a we're gonna
have a great time we're going to talk
about our nation we're going to talk
about where we're going where we've come
from and I can tell you on Cova door
coronavirus or whatever you want to call
it plenty names tremendous progress is
being made I spoke with the governor of
Texas where they've done a fantastic job
but he said they have had some outbreaks
in prisons and that's where their
numbers went out
the numbers change a little bit because
of the prison population but he's got it
in great shape Texas Florida's doing
very well George is doing very well we
have tremendous numbers we have hot
spots as I said you might and we take
care of the hot spots but many of the
governors have done a very good job some
not as good as others some very good but
Oklahoma has been a place that I think
one of the reasons we chose it is
because of how well that because it's
early it's very early and because of
what a great job the governor and
everybody else has done in Oklahoma and
we expect to have you know it's like a
record-setting crowd we've never had an
empty seat and we certainly won't in
Oklahoma Mike you want to talk about how
well Oklahoma's done relative to other
places
certainly mr. president we president I
both spoken to governor Kevin stead in
the last several days and even earlier
today and Oklahoma has really been in
the forefront of our efforts to slow the
spread and and in a very real sense they
flattened the curve and today their
hospital capacity is is abundant the
number of cases in Oklahoma has declined
precipitously and we feel very confident
going forward and with the rally this
coming weekend you're working closely
with the governor will have will have
measures in place to be screening people
coming in to the facilities and but
Oklahoma's really led the way in
demonstrating we safely reopen and so as
as as we gather to hear from the
President and hear about the stakes in
this election will also be celebrating a
state that's demonstrated every day that
you can you can put health first and and
open up and do all those things at the
same time and like you gave me a number
before nationwide overall how are we
doing well it's it's it's really
remarkable mr. president with more than
22 million tests having been
performed across the country we we
continue to see overall that the what's
called the positive test rate remains
very stable in the country as we said
earlier mr. president there's a few
states where the positivity rate is
climbing and we're working very closely
with those governors to identify that
you mentioned in the state of Texas
there was one County where there were
literally three prisons that had
individual outbreaks that accounted for
literally hundreds of new cases in a
single day we're also seeing in Imperial
County California people hoo-hoo-hoo
Americans who may live on the opposite
side of the border in Mexico coming home
in and that's showing up in some of
their numbers but overall the American
people I think are to be commended mr.
president that because of the steps
they've taken and continue to take we're
demonstrating we could safely reopen and
where we saw coronavirus positive cases
six weeks ago over 30,000 now it's
averaged in in recent weeks roughly
20,000 new cases a day as I said the
positivity rate remains flat
hospitalizations for coronavirus are
declining all over the country and most
importantly our fatality rate continues
over a seven-day average to continue to
decline president's always quick to say
one loss of life is to men but when we
think about a matter of a month and a
half ago when when we were we were
losing 2,500 Americans a day now that we
see the numbers declining so
precipitously I think it's a real
tribute to our health care workers
tribute to every American that has
demonstrated each and every day that we
can reopen our country but we can
continue to put the health particularly
of our most vulnerable first and
yesterday's number was approximately
what according to some public reporting
mr. president I'll have more deep
later this afternoon less than 400
fatalities yesterday all across the
country that's a far cry for what it was
a month ago or two months ago and it's a
lot 400 people too much shouldn't happen
at all China should not have let it
happen but it happened all over the
world that's happened which is a very
sad thing but our numbers really the low
watermark and it's getting better and
it'll he'll end up being gone we're
making very good headway with respect to
vaccines Alex so we're making very good
headway therapeutically and a cure was
really grew I think really really
tremendous headway I've seen the results
I've met with some of the people that do
the work smart people great people
people that have succeeded before I
think vaccines are coming along far in
advance of what they thought they would
be and I think we'll have some very good
news for you on vaccines and
therapeutics and cures frankly because I
guess you know if you look at
therapeutics if it acts fast enough I
guess you call it a cure wouldn't you
say so I think we're gonna have some
very good news on that but we're too low
a low mark and some of them like in
Texas we had a prison population that
was that went heavy and now it's
controlled so we understand the disease
we've learned I was with the governor of
New Jersey the other night and we had a
great talk about economic development
and we're going to be doing a big bridge
that they've been looking for for I
guess he said since 1918 they've been
looking to redo it so it's a long that's
a long time but and we've agreed to do
that about 900 million dollars but he
had mentioned 2,500 deaths or 12,500
deaths
12,500 deaths and out of that there was
one death under 18 I said say it again
so it was over 12,000 I guess the exact
number was 12,500 and they did the study
from that point and out of that one
death was under
at the age of 18 which is pretty amazing
I I knew it was which tells me the
schools hopefully going to be back in
the fall they're gonna be back in full
blast but the young people ever strong
immune systems I imagine that's the
reason but they've come out of this at a
level that's in really inconceivable by
the way the regular flu are the flus
other things SARS or h1n1 any of them if
you look at the young people they were
affected like everybody else but for
whatever reason with respect to coverage
the numbers are very very low so yep he
says he's asked for it and we're sending
it well I can't complain about it I took
it for two weeks and I'm here here we
are and we've had some great studies I
didn't know about the report that Jeff
asked about or the statement but we've
had some great reports for coming out of
France coming out of Spain coming out of
other places the only place we don't get
necessarily reports are coming out of
Alex's agency or wherever they come from
I don't understand that Alex what is it
exactly because I have heard I have had
so many people that were so thrilled
with the results from hydroxy so what is
that exactly well your direction
we continue to study especially in
earlier phase so a lot of the data that
has come out that was more negative was
people who were quite ill in the
hospital people that were like seriously
yeah like they weren't gonna make it
let's give a little hydroxy and then
they don't make and they say oh well
maybe the president was wrong all I know
is that we've had some tremendous
reports I've had a lot of people tell me
that they think it saved their lives you
know the one woman was a fantastic woman
their representative from Detroit she
she was fantastic but there are many
people like that to say the same thing
so I don't know but I took it and I felt
good
about taking it I don't know if it had
an impact but it certainly didn't hurt
me I feel I feel good to reverse our
decision on terminating the relationship
with it WI so would you consider that I
don't know I have to see what they're
asking I have no idea what they're
asking I have no idea what they're
asking but I'll take a look at the World
Health Organization has been very
disappointing to the world
they've been disappointing and we as you
know paid 450 million dollars and close
to 500 million dollars on some years but
for years and years we've paid far more
than anybody else and they've been a
puppet of China and so no I'm not
reconsidering unless they get their act
together and I'm not sure they can at
this point but maybe certainly over the
years they might but they have been a
disaster they were wrong on every call
including what I said we're going to
close up the United States to people
coming in from China where China was
heavily infected at that time and
possibly still is and I closed it and
there was a wise decision there were a
lot of people even on the other side the
enemies will call him the enemy they
said that was an incredible decision I
don't know how Trump made that decision
but he made that decision to we save
thousands of lives hundreds of thousands
of lives yeah go ahead I don't know I'd
have to ask the Attorney General but I
will say if he's doing a book I think
it's totally inappropriate that he does
a book I think a guy I gave him a break
he couldn't get Senate confirmed he was
never sent and confirmed the first time
I don't think he's supposed to even be
calling himself an ambassador because he
couldn't get Senate confirmed he got in
through a little trick and he was there
for a fairly short period of time I put
him here because he couldn't get Senate
confirmed this was a non Senate
confirmed position as you know he stayed
for a short while and I felt that it was
not appropriate that he's standing
longer I wasn't impressed
and somebody said he went out and wrote
a book if he wrote a book I can't
imagine that he can because that's
highly classified information even
conversations with me they're highly
classified I told that to the Attorney
General before I will consider every
conversation with me as president highly
classified so that would mean that if he
wrote a book and if the book gets out
he's broken the law and I would think
that he would have criminal problems I
hope so otherwise I mean they put a
sailor in jail because he sent a
photograph of his bed and a and an
engine of an old submarine and if this
guy's writing writing things about
conversations or about anything and
maybe he's not telling the truth he's
been known not to tell the truth a lot
so we'll have to see what the book is
all about but you know a lot of people
are upset with him for writing a book a
lot of people are very angry with him
for writing a book but it's up to the
Attorney General Bill do you have
anything to say about well people who
come to work in the government and have
access to sensitive information
generally sign an agreement that says
that when they leave government if they
write something that as a that draws on
or or might reflect some of the
information they've had access to they
have to go through a clearance process
before they can publish the book and we
don't believe that Bolton went through
that process hasn't completed the
process therefore is in violation of
that agreement and that's criminal
liability by the way you're talking
about you're not talking about like he's
got to return three dollars that he made
on a book that's called criminal
liability that's a big thing you know
Hillary Clinton she deleted 33,000
emails and if we ever found out what
those emails say she would have had a
liability that's what you have you have
a liability tell us what the DOJ is
doing a number of things but the thing
that is front and center right now is
trying to get them to complete the
process go through the process and make
the necessary
deletions of classified information
being printed okay according to sources
it's being printed hasn't been released
they said what we were doing is trying
to get him to complete the clearance
process that's required
he hasn't completed the process he never
completed the process he knew that
president really I don't know if any
book that's been published so quickly
Wow
you know the office holders are still in
government and it's about very current
events and current leaders and current
discussions and current policy issues
which many of which are inherently
classified I haven't seen it I haven't
seen it but he knows and he was advised
not to write it and he was advised very
strongly not to write it until it's
cleared and he couldn't wait and we'll
see what happens but I think he's got
personally I would imagine his like hey
when you do classified that to me is a
very strong criminal problem and he
knows he's got classified information
any conversation with me is less but
then it becomes even worse if he lies
about the conversation which I
understand he might have in some cases
so we'll see what happens there in court
or they'll soon be in court but he
understands he did not complete a
process or anywhere near complete a
process
criticism from congressional Republicans
including representative Cheney about
your decision to withdraw troops from
Germany are you so we have 52,000
soldiers in Germany that's a tremendous
amount of soldiers it's tremendous cost
in the United States and Germany as you
know is very delinquent in their
payments to NATO and they're paying 1%
and there's supposed to be a 2 percent
and the 2 percent is very low it should
be much more than that so they're
delinquent of billions of dollars and
this is four years
delinquent so we're removing a number
down to we're putting the number down to
25,000 soldiers we'll see what happens
but Germany has not been making payment
in addition to that I was the one that
brought it up everybody talks about
Trump with Russia well I brought this up
a long time ago why is Germany paying
Russia billions of dollars for energy
and then we're supposed to protect
Germany from Russia how does that work
it doesn't work
so Germany's delinquent they've been
delinquent for years and they own NATO
billions of dollars and they have to pay
it so we're protecting Germany and their
delinquent that doesn't make sense so I
said we're going to bring down the
soldier count to 25,000 soldiers
it varies it's around 52,000 now but it
varies but it's a lot and as you know
those are well paid soldiers they live
in Germany they spend vast amounts of
money in Germany everywhere around those
bases is very prosperous for Germany so
Germany takes and then on top of it they
treat us very badly on Drake we have a
trade with the EU and Germany being the
biggest member very very badly on trade
and we're negotiating with them on that
but right now I'm not satisfied with the
deal they want to make of course the
United States hundreds of billions of
dollars over the years on trade so we we
get hurt on trade and we get hurt on
NATO
now with NATO I've raised other
countries a hundred and forty billion
dollars they're paying a hundred and
forty billion dollars more
because I interceded I said look you
know we're protecting you you have to
pay your bills because it was going like
this until I got here now it's gone like
a rocket ship but one of the only
countries that hasn't agreed to pay what
they're supposed to pay is Germany so I
said until they pay we're removing our
soldiers a number of our soldiers by
about half and then when we get down to
25,000 we'll see where we're going but
Germany has been delinquent and why
should we be doing what we're doing if
they don't pay and they're supposed to
pay and the number they're supposed to
pay actually at 2% the 2% should be
higher and we're also talking about for
many years this isn't a new phenomena
this is going on for many years where
they've taken advantage of the United
States but everybody has under Biden and
under Obama what they've done to this
country is unbelievable and I'm not only
talking about Germany by the way I'm
talking about plenty of other countries
but NATO now is paying a hundred and
forty billion dollars more if you look
at secretary the secretary-general who's
terrific Stoltenberg he's been terrific
he's probably my biggest fan he said
nobody else could have done what Trump
did because I raised the other countries
by a hundred and forty billion dollars
because we end up paying the difference
the United States pays the difference to
protect Europe so we protect them and
then they take advantage of us on trade
for many many years we're not talking
about now less so now for many years so
we're working there to deal with them
but it's it's very unfair and I would
say by far the worst abuser is Germany
you said last week on Seattle that if
the mayor of Seattle the governor of
Washington didn't take steps to end the
occupation of the Capitol Hill
neighborhood you would step in and you
would do something that they still
haven't ended it they're negotiating are
you considering taking actually you know
and garbage removal vinegar these people
have taken over a vast part a major part
a very good part of a place called
Seattle
Seattle's big stuff that's a major city
and we have a governor's as stiff and we
have a mayor who said oh this is going
to be a love fest and by the way these
are violent people that took it over
these are not people that are nice
people I saw her in your network today
John I saw what went on with the hitting
and the punching and the beating and all
the other things going on in Seattle and
you have a governor that doesn't do a
damn thing about it and you have a mayor
that doesn't know she's alive she's
talking about it's gonna be a love fest
this summer know if they don't do the
job I'll do the job and I've already
spoken to the Attorney General about it
but if they don't do the job we will do
the job about ten different things
either any one of which will solve the
problem quickly to go through any lists
we can do a lot of things I think it's
incredible also that the radical left
press doesn't cover it they're acting
like nothing happened you turn on the
news you look at the news you look you
don't even see stories about it
if the write ever took over a city
conservative Republicans took over a
city it would be the biggest story in
history you can't even find stories
about Seattle it's incredible they've
taken over
we'll say they've - I tell you what the
American public is very angered by that
Seattle is a major important city and
the Democrats
I guess you say radical left but it's
not even radical left it's just Democrat
where we have a problem
or Democrat run cities if you look at
Minneapolis if you look at other cities
that have had trouble there Democrat in
virtually every case that I can think of
I can't think of one other case these
are Democrat Ron cities Minneapolis
where the police are told to run run run
for your lives don't do anything and if
I didn't get involved and send in the
National Guard and it was at my
insistence that they did that
and as soon as I did that everything
stopped in Minneapolis four days five
days later there's no timeline we're
watching it very closely these are
violent people that are dealing
violently and I think what would what
I'd like to see before we do something
I'd like to see the press kit and it
cover it because they're not it's not
that they're covering it badly they're
hardly covering at all think of this a
group and Tifa and others radical left's
they went into a major u.s. city seattle
and they took over a big percentage of
that city and the press doesn't want to
cover it and we have a mayor who's
scared stiff she isn't or what's
happening we have a governor that's one
of the most overrated politicians in the
country he just ran for president he got
less than 1% he actually probably I
would have said less than zero but I'm
not sure that's possible he got nothing
he got no votes nothing he and the whole
thing that guy was out there fighting at
the end he got zero right
zero so he found and now he goes back
and they take over a city and he doesn't
say anything about it worse he said he
didn't hear a day later he said I never
I didn't hear anything about it
they took over a city Seattle and he
said I didn't hear anything about it so
look the governor has to call out the
troops to what he has to do has to call
out the National Guard has to do
something because you know the problem
with what happened in Seattle is it
spreads and all of a sudden they'll say
let's do some other city and let's do
another one and we're not gonna let it
happen so timing wise they were all set
to go
we're watching the process but the most
amazing thing about the process is how
the fake news media doesn't want to
cover it to me that's the most amazing
thank you all very much I appreciate
[Music]
Saturday night will be a big day that's
a big night I hope you're all going to
be there it's going to be very big
[Music]
you